let's get into hatred mail for the week
quick reminder if you don't remember
what hatred mail is this is what we're
talking about we're so all right it's
wrong patriot mail written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman yep because
America and because freedom all right
this is a voice mail a hatred mail that
I don't think will surprise you to hear
did not come from an actual lawyer even
though they are making some legal
suggestions for what Donald Trump should
do to me let's take a listen to it
together and see if we can decipher Park
Man on fake news CN n his Park man
wearing makeup so young to be so jaded
refused heads to open his eye yotube
should ban him for actual propaganda old
news fake news communist news in fact
Trump should sue Pakman for libel that's
right we might have done something on
the program that's libel Asst not
libelous but libel Asst and for that
Donald Trump should sue us what's the
deal with the makeup thing like well it
is what would I don't wear makeup on the
program although I've been advised by a
number of people that it might not be a
terrible idea to toss a little powder on
just because of the the shine of the
bright lights Pat yes it's it's quite
quite hot under the under the lights but
like what would be it would that be
effeminate if a man was wearing makeup
on a television program well he's
referencing the time that you were on
CNN so when you went on CNN years ago
were you wearing makeup for that
interview absolutely I asked to double
it up I needed as much of it as possible
are you crazy under those lights with
Erin Burnett I don't want to show up and
have her look at me like I'm chopped
liver or something like that yeah so
John I said please and and fill in my
eyebrows my goodness I need to uh I need
as much help as possible here okay I'm
kidding about the filling in my eyebrows
thing but my eyebrows I think are thick
enough on their own but that's a topic
probably not for a different day but for
never yeah and I think if Trump sued us
for libel or libel either one he'd
probably lose because he's done this
before he sued Bill Maher over and
Ranga Tang joke yes yes yes dude someone
for saying that he's not a billionaire
he always loses these libel lawsuits if
Trump Sue's us for libel I would ask
that a judge file and an injection I
mean why not right just just this throw
out whatever whatever occurs to me you
can turn hatred mail Pat lack like that
one it this you can turn hatred mail
into something positive with the coupon
code hey tree at 40 if you use the
coupon code hey tree at 40 when you sign
up for membership at david pakman.com
slash membership you get a 40% discount
and i don't know about you but 40% off
for a hundred percent of the benefits
sounds pretty pretty good to me